Ryan is in Bakersfield California hi
Ryan welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
Dave how's it going better than I
deserve what's up hey Dave so since
April of last year I didn't want to say
thank you for the things you've done
since April of last year
I paid off 30 of the 50 grand that I owe
that wheedled
and now I just got one more loan to go
good for you it'll only go you know
thank you my goal is to get out before
Christmas but they're all bad throughout
that time I had a wife that was only
about 40% on board and today we just
followed our taxes and we're getting
about like 2112
and I did what you said you recommend
there's people to do um lay down on the
table and look at it and say what are we
going to do with it I obviously want to
throw it all on bit she wants to throw
half of it on our emergency fund and I
know she low-key wants to fund more our
daughter's upcoming birthday party which
we've been saving and planning on the
budget but she she really likes to you
know you know how on the instagrams they
do the whole going all out thing that's
what she wants to do and she feels that
the money that we're saving for it's not
going to be enough and I tell her well
you know we're paying off debt and then
that's when the discussion starts to
happen what do you recommend me to do
Dave um just a side note she refuses to
go to marriage counseling and I don't
see the point of dragging her through it
what should I think they've really don't
know how I can get my wife on board all
this mm-hmm well you're trying to fix
what to do and you haven't gotten
together on the why we're doing it and
when your family is in debt and is not
in a position to have a bright future
spending money on Instagram or the
birthday party is immature and childish
and so the the obviously your wife does
not have the does not have the same
vision that you've got for your finances
and so it's not a matter of the what to
do with a refund what to do with the
refund not agreeing on that it's a
symptom of the fact that y'all don't
agree on anything and so you know you're
gonna have to sit down and you guys are
going to try to find a way some common
ground to look to the future and say
we're sacrificing for the future and
we're willing to do that together we're
on the same team I have no good news for
you I have no data points of people who
drug a spouse kicking and screaming into
wealth kicking and screaming and bucking
along the way
like a wild horse against everything
you're trying to do there's no data
points of anybody building wealth with a
spouse that's doing that I can't find
any by the desert there may be somebody
that did it I just never met them and no
one in any of our research does that and
so basically the cause of your
disagreement about your future you are
dooming your future and so you've got to
get on the same page it's not about a
birthday party it's not about a tax
refund those are minor things if you
were on the same page and you were in
complete agreement and you were going to
work together to sacrifice to win and
you want to cheat and steal some of the
money and throw it at an Instagram
birthday that doesn't keep you from
becoming wealthy but but not being on
the same page and constantly being at
odds the way you all are right now does
tell me you're not going to be a bill
well doing that so and I showed her how
in the vision that I want to build the
you know how it all works out I walked
her through it and she just doesn't
really believe it they um she um growing
up with her parents you saw how they
still lose money and their broker than
ever you know they fight like cotton
cotton so again bless their hearts I
love them but she saw how they struggle
financially and she even mentioned to me
one point that she just doesn't want to
worry about her
think about the money just also having
no I'm gonna day this she's 21 time 27
okay
well part of it is she's acting like a
child I just want someone to take care
of me and I don't want to have to deal
with reality that's what you just told
me yeah okay
and so I think you put your arm around
her and just say baby I just don't wants
to be like your parents I don't want us
to be like Joe and Susie over there I
don't want to be like Henry and Sally
over there look at them they fight all
the time and they're losing the battle
all they do is work and they have
nothing right and yeah we're just not
gonna do that you and me we can do
better than that you and me we can win
and I can show you mean we can walk
together and show you how to win here so
yeah I do think you need to go see a
marriage counselor I think you need to
sit down your pastor and start to get on
the same page and let's do this would
she go to the Financial Peace University
class if I gave it to you can you get
her to actually go to the class I can
talk her into it as she'll party what's
the online classes no no no she needs to
go to the doctor I can phone right on
the home line it's not good enough for
her she needs to be in a class with
other people who were doing this and she
sees other people doing this she just
mentioned that our local church nearby
said that they're hosting it and she
didn't know she wasn't moaning about it
she actually kind of fitted us I'm like
hey check it out yeah well I'll tell you
what I'll put you on hold wife kelly
pick up but only if you guys both agree
to go to the class and attend every
class i do not want to give this to you
and you go and this cause your divorce i
don't want to give this to you and her
act like she's 12
i'm not going to put up with that i'm
too old for that so if the two of you
together can make a promise to kelly
that you will actually attend each of
the nine lessons nine weeks in a row one
night each week for nine weeks i will
pay for it and send the two of you
through and that will also include all
the on lines for the whole year but you
have to
you're gonna go to the class and you
have to keep your promise because if you
can't do that then I can help you grow
up I can help her grow up and it sounds
like it's time for her to grow up and if
she's 51 or she's 21 she's still acting
like a child
and and that's what you're dealing with
here this is I'm throwing a temper fit
because I want to have an Instagram
birthday party for my kid and I'm 21
years old and that's exactly what's
going on here
so I'm not trying to be mean I'm just
telling you the truth and to not tell
you the truth would actually be mean so
if you guys both want to go to the class
I would love to have the two of you go
to class and I will participate and you
guys go on to the next level in your
life you have the ability to change your
family tree you do not have to end up
like her parents none of us have to end
up like our parents unless you want to
because your parents are awesome you
know I mean so whatever you want to do
but that's the thing you get to make
choices people and we'll help you with
that but you have to make Kelly that
promise so you hold on and I'll have her
pick up